hello and welcome to our conversation
with Matt Bailey best-selling author SEO
and marketing expert and worldwide
corporate trainer today we'll be
discussing and taking your questions on
what's new and in the future for search
engine optimization seo isn't what it
used to be so if you're still using last
year's tried-and-true tactics to lure
traffic to your website landing pages or
content you probably already noticed a
drop in response along with the changing
algorithms of Google and others SEO has
transformed dramatically even over the
past few months alone luckily you are
not alone because today Matt Bailey will
start by demystifying the latest SEO
challenges and the changes and will
predict what slightly coming ahead we
also invite you to pick Matt's brain
with your own specific SEO queries I'm
dan be venerable sibilance director of
training research and your moderator
today
there's my pleasure to introduce you to
our expert guest Matt Bailey how you
doing Matt I'm doing all right Dan how
you doing today that's great so that
Bailey is a best-selling author
marketing expert corporate trainer and
professional speaker he's the founder
and president of site logic marketing
and matt is a digital marketing
instructor for the digital marketing
Association in New York City a member of
the digital marketing faculty for simply
learn and an instructor for the osep
that's the online marketing certified
professional program he's the author of
internet marketing an hour of a day
wired to be wowed and teach new dogs old
tricks matt excels at combining his
marketing background with programming
know-how to help companies create
comprehensive strategies that improve
their online presence and conversion so
once again Matt I really am happy to
have you with us talking about SEO which
is a really up your bailiwick your Matt
bailiwick yeah good way to say in it but
yeah it's I've been doing SEO since
about 1996 now so it's been quite a
while just to watch this industry grow
change adapt modify itself over the
years and I think the next few years
are probably going to be probably the
most amount of adaptation SEO s are
going to have to do more so than in the
previous 20 okay well to get this
conversation started here's a preview of
what Matt will be talking about today
keyword research and search trends SEO
friendly copywriting content
optimization website and landing page
optimization content trends analytics
and of course we'll be answering your
questions throughout so feel free to
chime in so with that I would just like
to hand the mic over for a bit here to -
Matt so take it away mr. beiley all
right well thank you Dan and as you can
tell by the agenda it seems to be
content heavy and that certainly without
an accident there that if you've been an
SEO for any length of time you can see
where things are moving in the digital
marketing industry or social media
content marketing those types of things
and so the role of the SEO is becoming
more critical than ever in being that
connection from what are people
searching for and then what do we
publish SEO is that critical link
between the research and the development
of content and that is only going to
increase more and more over the next few
years so that's why there's a little bit
more of emphasis on that content side
that you'll see there but just you know
a little bit more in detail on that that
the role of SEO has primarily been as
that the first line of understanding
what the search engine is doing what do
they require what are the new
technologies coming out of search and
what are the trends coming from search
how is Google changing results but be
testing so LCOS first and foremost are
on those front lines of seeing what
especially google google is pushing the
envelope more than anybody and they're
testing more thing
and so understanding what is Google
doing what are the implications of it is
this just a test or are we moving what's
the bigger picture of what they're
attempting to do and so understanding
that role there of being that early
predictor of what's going on with Google
and then being able to translate that
inside your organization or inside your
agency that is really becoming part of
you know the representative role of the
search engine optimizer is understanding
here's what's happening and here's how
we're supposed to react to it at the
very base level it's understanding those
keywords it's understanding what are
people searching for and what is their
intent and how do we then apply that
into our content strategy so that has
been really kind of the foundational
part of what an SEO does but it's also
going to be a little bit larger into
looking at the larger trends of what is
Google attempting to do what are the
implications and how do we respond to
that now of course with part of that
keyword research is understanding the
long-term trends over a year two years
three years because if something has a
trend and it's predictable well then
that's something you can bring into your
organization because I love to say if
it's predictable its monetizable you can
make money off it if you know that it's
going to happen every year because you
can prepare for it you can help your
organization prepare for those increases
in traffic especially if you're able to
tie those trends into specific events if
you can come up with causality what
causes those to happen how do we react
to it how can we develop that and how
can we incorporate that into our
strategy again that is more of a
planning and prospecting work that a
search engine optimizer would do and
those skills of doing keyword research
and understanding the long term view of
keyword research of
throughout the year creating those
connections that is a valuable skill
which is only going to increase and of
course those keywords are important for
anyone in a marketing field or also
customer service we've seen more and
more of this cross marketing view across
an organization where marketing is
getting more involved in customer
service they're getting more involved in
loyalty they're getting more involved in
many different aspects of nurturing
customers the customer experience and so
whenever you're planning any of these
things for social media and what are we
doing with social media are we educating
are we rewarding are we trying to look
for new customers well all of that
requires content that content is going
to have to be researched as to when do
we talk about certain things and how do
we talk about certain things
keyword research gives you that agenda
it keyword research tells you when
people search for certain content and
also the associated words that they have
and so that applies to your content
marketing your social media marketing it
also applies to when people become
customers and if you do any amount of
CRM marketing email marketing or email
automation or even triggered your
keyword research can help in developing
the content that will be in those emails
because you'll have done the research
and find out what do people want after
they make a decision after they purchase
a product what are the needs that they
have what does the information need that
they have and how do we write towards
that so again
SEO is influencing the content that is
generated by the entire organization in
nearly all communications this gets back
to seeing the trends that are happening
within the search engine and you've
probably seen this lately I love this
example here so if I want to make a
latte and I type that into Google
this is what's interesting the answer to
my question is at the top of the page
now without even going to the website I
can have my answer further question and
now there's a couple implications to
this yes it's great we can be at the top
of the rankings you can have our answer
there but if the answer completely
answers the searchers question it
doesn't generate a page view they don't
see much of our brand they aren't really
they aren't engaging with us at all
they're engaging with Google and so this
gets to the point of how do you then
bring this to the organization as far as
a strategic view of this how do we
approach it how does this change what we
do with our website or with our content
you can also see here that people are
asking different questions and this gets
to the copywriting of the website are
you generating content that answers
questions because this is where Google
is pooling this information as well as
pulling the related questions that come
from that type of content this also is
critical because this then leads into
voice search and so you've got a home
sis didn't use any of the phone
assistance or guess what this is coming
in cars that you will have a voice
assistant in cars and your search result
will be read back to you and this is the
beginning stages of that that if you
have a question or a search you would
speak your search and then the first
result would be read back to you and as
you can see it's not coming from the
site it's coming from Google so this is
where again we sit down we look at the
strategy what are we trying to do what
is our strategy as far as visibility in
the search results and what's going to
happen and what's happening now with
this is you could be answering people's
questions and never knowing it simply
based because Google is delivering the
result they're not going to your site
a possibility of them going to your site
exists but as more voice searches are
being generated Google is going to
deliver a result that doesn't require a
click through because it's all happening
through audio so hopefully this doesn't
all the changes in SEO I would say over
the past 15 years have been largely
external driven by Google as Google has
taken away keywords taken away keywords
and analytics done numerous things here
that have caused SEO s to have to react
and again this is one of those changes
that causes us to sit and figure out how
are we going to deal with this change we
have some questions already one of which
it Google's not spending so much time
focusing on keywords specifically even
though they're still important where do
you suggest that marketers look for
keywords oh I think the the typical
keyword research tools are still very
viable in fact you'll probably get
better information out of keyword tools
than you will Google's keyword tool
Google has been combining keyword
concepts under a single keyword so for
example a a great one that we've seen in
the keyword research a pool table and
pool tables plural and singular Google
puts that all under pool table whereas
anyone who you know does any amount of
e-commerce can tell you there was a
world of difference between people that
search for plural and singular before
the changes in keywords I could tell you
with numerous sites that we had that if
people searched with the singular
version they were about three to five
times more likely to purchase than if
they searched for the plural version the
plural version meant that they were
shopping the singular version pointed to
they were ready to make a decision so
Google won't show you the data however
between the plural and singular for pool
tables other keyword
search tools however will show you that
so even though you know even though it's
getting more difficult with the keywords
from a marketing standpoint absolutely
still do your keyword research right as
if you would uh you know you're gonna
have to do additional research maybe you
know customer research you know face to
face asking them to describe how they
would search or what they were looking
for what problem you solved because
you're going to need a wider variety of
input for keywords yeah and if you have
any way to look in your competitors I
know there are some tools that let you
let you do that you can see what your
competitors are at least in their or
their SEM you can learn a lot yes by
what yeah because a you can you can tell
a lot by what's valuable keywords by
learning what your competitors are
paying for and also check your ticker
analytics to see how people are actually
finding you what's interesting is how is
how is right I know the right brain is
one of the most influential parts of
Google now and I know that that's
basically lumping instead of creating
separate pages for plurals and other
iterations of words rank range is sort
of including all of that looking for
those words in general content is it how
was ranked brain affecting search terms
and SEO with just keywords um you know
it's really trying to learn more of what
exactly do people want from an
intentional standpoint so trying to put
together unfamiliar searches or
unfamiliar for evenings or I think I'd
better today um trying to think whose
name it was but it was a Matthew
McConaughey his name in one week had
like eight thousand misspelled
variations mm-hmm okay somehow you know
a search engine has to figure out who
took over eight thousand misspellings
who did you mean you know who are you
trying to figure out
you know so it's it's trying to figure
out the intent and deliver the right
result and you know I think part of this
is yes they don't want SEO s to be
focusing on individual words and by
taking away all that data you know in a
way they have accomplished that so you
know what rankbrain is attempting to do
is trying to tie those things together
of how do we figure out now they're
looking at them I knew shut up infamous
workers
they do not want to show it to us right
so it's not a whole lot you can do but
it's just you know it's from their
standpoint the best thing you can do is
just continue to write great content
that people want hmm
that answers their questions using a
variety of using a variety of words that
explain you know a great example is you
know if you're writing an article uh you
know baseball season started here in the
US if you're writing an article about
baseball you're going to use words like
umpire like ball strikes bats teams
those are all words that build context
and so they're going to count just as
much as the primary term baseball and in
fact Google is going to look for all
those other terms that that build that
context and so it's it's not so much
that single word anymore it's that
variety of I would call the second tier
words to support the context of what
you're writing about roses are coming
more into play and and of course putting
that in a and a more natural language
type of type of phraseology in your
content rather than yes the old days of
key words how many key words can we
stuff in the first paragraph what's the
optimum number of words in the in the
meta tag
I mean because now really if it looks
like you're I mean this googles and
penalizing people for doing stuff like
that for years but now especially with
rankbrain that the more you can do to
look to write like a conversation that
people are actually thinking and asking
about
sure is a better way they've always
wanted that I mean that has always been
Google's goal from the beginning they
have told us to write for humans but the
problem has been is you know there are a
lot of SEO s there that would rather
take the formulaic approach and you know
why should I write for humans I'm just
trying to get people to my site you know
I want it they're going to buy and so
they you know try to reverse-engineer
everything to come up with a formula of
use this keyword this many times and
this part of the page and you know
whereas Google has always said right for
humans first and so by taking away some
of those other options or taking away
the keywords it's really guided the
industry to do what they wanted to do
and honestly I think it's it's a good
thing because the quality of content has
to increase it has to get better and
that is one way that they've enforced
that what exactly what they've imposed
their will on people who desire to have
better rankings right they just have one
one more question that people a lot of
people are asking if you have any
specific recommendations for for keyword
research tools before we Wow there are a
lot of them um so if you've got like
Raven or um trying to think what are
some of the others Raven SEO tools um
there's one right on the edge of mic on
wood trackers to word tracker yeah um oh
I've got a list of them somewhere here
you could yeah we can fly that out yeah
just look do Google out and look at some
of the keyword research tools
um there are a lot of them many of them
offer free trials and so yeah just get
in do the free trial take a look at
what's there um yeah yeah some come with
full service site management you may not
want all that you may you may want that
others are more standalone independent
they just do keyword research never
choose a keyword research tool that
doesn't show up at least
on page 10 of the SERPs but yeah and
honestly the more you do keyword
research I have always felt this way and
it the more you do keyword research the
better equipped you are to do your job
and by that it's dissecting the keywords
what are people looking for what are the
trends what do they associate what are
the people places and things so as
you're looking at the keywords you're
not so much looking to see the volume
that someone searched for you know by a
you know by a pink car that's that's a
greater you know that's good but they
talked about cars they talked about
buying and they talked about color
that's more of what we're looking for is
let's start slicing and dicing this down
what words are they associating what
colors what features and by
understanding the breadth of how people
search and the questions they have it
helps you write better content because
now you understand not just optimizing
for one word people have questions
across an entire breadth of type style
color place city in all these types of
things and so that's really what I
challenge people to get out of keyword
research is understanding the full
breadth of what people want rather than
just a single word or a single phrase
this gets into copywriting AC like I
said when you when you get into you know
our people looking for colors are the
people looking for locations sizes I
want to understand the breadth of what
they're talking about and that helps me
become a better copywriter
I can understand intent if I know the
questions that they have then we can
write answers and so you know I want to
see how people are searching you know a
great example is is now we've seen
searches increasing for people searching
for you know the best or the top rated
or theorem use I think is yeah oh yeah
for me people are actually typing in
what is the best car for me
and I think what they're doing
essentially is is directly asking Google
you know based on the two million things
you know about me would be the best car
for me so people are looking for more
personalized information so what you can
do is get into the you know the how to
the why the you know what it means all
these different cues that people are
giving in their key phrases develop your
content to answer those questions yeah
I've actually seen a statistic that
eighty-two percent of smartphone users
use and this is for businesses looking
for businesses use specifically the term
near me after their search
so even geographically I don't know if
that's anything you conclude in the
content but well not you know it's it's
blows my mind because um if they're on
their smartphone they're automatically
going to get results near them that
that's kind of interesting so it's more
of a cue for Google than it is for a
website because to use that phrase in
any of your optimization really wouldn't
make a lot of sense because you don't
know who's near you um and if anything
especially on a mobile search Google is
pretty much going to ignore that near me
because you're going to get the results
near where you are anyway yeah um so
yeah getting into the search data people
search for what they need they they
figure out what they're looking for but
now here is where the role of the SEO is
going to come in organizationally is
that when you add people writing content
generating content for content marketing
for social media especially if you're
working with you know like a publisher
who is constantly developing content now
you need to help them come up with ways
to measure success and also to motivate
them to implement SEO tactics in their
writing so rather than developing catchy
headlines that may have a double meaning
that may not
well in search you need to help
copywriters understand that you will
your headline while that might look
great on print in search it's actually
going to cause a problem and so you turn
into an educator for your content
developers you're teaching them what
works well what's going to click well
what's going to look well in the search
engines versus what might be confusing
also uh it's also helping them to
understand you know a great example of
this um and before I move on someone um
gave me a great example as they were
writing an article about holiday time
travel and that was the title of the
article that they put out there and they
couldn't figure out why this article was
consistently getting hundreds or
thousands of visits a month well after
it was published and when we went back
and started looking at some of the
rankings and some of the keywords and
things like that we found out that the
article was ranking really well for time
travel even though the headline was
holiday time travel so it's helping your
writers understand uh you know what
makes a good title but then also one
thing that I worked with one publisher
and one of the things we did to motivate
the writers was to develop like a
leaderboard of whose content is
generating the most visits and not only
that whose content is generating the
most new visits to the website and then
you can carry that through to you know
for how four different writers how many
visits or views have you generated in a
month or over the past six months
how much is your content performed
compared to other content and you can
carry this all the way out to you know
which writers had the highest amount of
AD clicks in their articles uh which
articles led to people to subscribe
again or you know even get into customer
lifetime value there's so many things
that you could implement so from an SEO
point you understand already how to look
at the success of in rankings and what
it generates in terms of pageviews
click-through is time on site click
depth uh you know all those types of
things that you can then develop into
helping others in the organization who
publish content start to measure the
impact of their writing organizationally
and then especially if you're able to
tie that to a financial implication that
shows that this is what its contributing
towards the business in terms of revenue
then you become the all-around hero
because you're able to help others tie
revenue to activity that's great we have
someone asking can just backfire on you
for example if you're starting every
headline with one weird this one weird
trick dot dot dot if you find that you
have a lot of if your bounce rate
immediately starts going up yeah because
if you're waiting for time travel or
star wars or something that everyone's
going to be looking for then could
actually negatively affect how Google
sees you if it's if you have all these
bounce rates they might see you as no
longer being relevant absolutely and
then it's not just Google with the
bounce rate it damages your brand it
drainages your credibility I mean it's
it's clickbait and I mean it doesn't
take long for people to realize click
betas click bait you can just look at
some of the data but yeah I mean when
you see articles or headlines that are
obvious click bait people are you know
you get caught a couple of times you get
fooled a couple of times it's not always
going to work and so this gets to you
know how are you positioning your brand
are you positioning your brand as a
trustworthy source of information that
answers people's questions are you
positioning your brand as we give people
what they need what they want
uh or are you fooling them to click on
an article based on what's popular right
now
you know there's a couple questions that
get to how the brand wants to be
perceived in the marketplace based on
tactics like that but great question
great question because clickbait is
powerful um but you got to ask yourself
are we giving people what they want or
are we fooling them into it and how will
that reflect on the brand right from
another keyword standpoint one thing
that I found is very valuable to do is
go out and look and see how people are
searching for the brand and content
associations they make with that brand
now this can also get into other areas
you may find that there's some crossover
where there is another company with a
similar brand name and so this will help
you understand a little bit more if you
get some of that crossover traffic but
also from a PR standpoint do people
associate content or ideas with your
brand that you would wrap this will help
you become aware of something that might
be out there that may not be getting
picked up so I enjoy doing these kinds
of searches because I want to know what
other words associations are people
making with the brand right you may need
to deal with yeah and also look at your
analytics and what it's linked in your
CRM to see I hope you have actually
converted because if you have some
longtail keywords in there that would be
good to generate content on that your
best customers are finding you through
that can be super valuable and least
compensate for having some super quick
baby word in there accidentally what's
interesting is that a people people are
a few people are really wanting to hone
in on this backtrack a bit here two ways
to capitalize on certain things that I
know people looking for quick answers to
rank high on Google the question keeps
coming up about for example is there any
ways why you could restructure your
content to capitalize on things like
near me like should you put in your
opening paragraph you know if you're
looking for a near that's that's almost
I I personally would would shrink from
doing that because I know that there's
something that that seems that a Google
I don't want to put words in your mouth
it seems like a Google is already doing
that automatically based on if you're
searching mobile but to it pretty soon
they're going to catch up to people
putting best and near me and because the
question like should I should I use
terms that are when I when I see the
results of who's commonly searched terms
and mobile should I put those in my in
my copy so what do you say about that
are they wasted that you can
legitimately without being penalized
capital P yeah well okay if you're
legitimately publishing an article that
is well researched comparing different
products and you title it best pet food
products or something like that that's a
legitimate case I have no problem with
that do your homework and create
something of value and it will do well
if it's good content that people like
now the veneer me is a bit more sketchy
because even though you may put on your
website something about near you or near
me I not everyone who visits your
website
remember this is more of a mobile
phenomenon these are people on their
phone looking for something near them a
drugstore a carwash you know something
like that a restaurant and that's being
computed based on distance based on you
know past preferences things like that
so it has nothing to do with the content
of your website what I would work on
more is your local business listing in
Google and developing more reviews for
your business and working with that
listing to
to add more pictures like I said reviews
they have a function there now where you
can add promotions the more you develop
that google listing that will do a
hundred times more to increase your
visibility when someone is looking for
something near them and they are near
you then adding words your website great
that's how smart I mean come across a
bit forcefully on some of these things
merely because a it's it has never
bothered me when people out now try to
fool Google with some really intelligent
things I somewhat tend to admire it uh
but when people try to fool Google with
what I would call amateurish things that
are poorly executed that's where I you
know that's where I get I get a little
ticked off at that because it's create a
quality experience that's what people
want quality experience and that's
really what it gets down to with you
know we with content marketing you're
answering people's questions and so as
people are generating that content
you're also sending them back to the
site you're sending them back to get
answers to register to do things like
that so all those web pages from the
content marketing that they're linking
to they need to be optimized for your
inbound strategy and what's interesting
is also from a paid search standpoint
the landing page from paid search you
know it needs to be optimized just like
any other page that's part of the
Quality Score algorithm does the landing
page reflect the paid search headline
does it also contain the keyword that
you're bidding on so you've got to look
at how people are developing their
landing pages internally and maybe you
can contribute to that as well in
helping improve the quality score
because the optimization of that landing
page is very similar where I see
employment and industry trends now this
is interesting because talking with the
director of OM CP a
and some of the surveys he's been doing
of hiring managers HR managers and
Technology uh or in marketing across the
across the the globe here one of the
things that he has seen if there is
becoming more demand of people who can
manage the entire tech marketing stack
not the single channel specialists
because more and more automation is
handling that more and more you know and
this is where we're going to see the
entrance of AI and machine learning is
adjusting your paid search campaign with
those minut methods of increasing your
click-through rate you know it's going
to be managing those bids so eventually
you're just going to focus more on the
content and eventually a is going to
take over the content so the demand is
for who were the single channel
specialists of SEO paid search social to
move into understanding the entire on
the channel digital marketing campaign
and can run and can change and can make
recommendations across the board for the
entire stack of digital marketing this
is where we're seeing more of the
employment trends going as well as the
skills demand is getting away from that
single hard skill to understanding the
entire campaign and that's going to go
into all different types of things
that's going to include email CRM social
display and SEO is I think are probably
very well positioned in all of these
things because of the foundation of
keywords the foundation of keywords and
understanding intent and then developing
content that answers those questions
that's needed an email it's needed in
automation it's needed and social and
display you know especially in the CRM
automation is someone has to write the
content that needs to be automated and
so again this then gets into looking at
the trends because automation you not
only need to write the content but you
- then plan the content when is it sent
when is this completed when is this done
so understanding the the sales cycles
and how long they go and when people
need certain information at what times
it takes that planning strategy of being
able to do that and I think SEO s are
well positioned and to understand that
full stack of marketing and the
implications as well as the management
of it and then we get to analytics this
is my favorite so as an SEO or if you're
taking on more of the the omni-channel
burden here you've got to develop those
measurements that show how effective not
only SEO has been but now content
management content management is big
everyone is moving towards it it has
become a significant piece of strategy
however what is lacking in content and
fit is the measurement how do we know
that this content piece that went out
whether it was a video whether it was an
infographic whether you know regardless
of what it was number one how do we
track performance number two how do we
know it affected anything
number three what was the pathway where
were we driving people and what did we
want them to do and how successful was
that and then also from an attribution
standpoint did this lead to other things
you know where did this content piece or
where does this channel help us overall
an attribution in driving new leads or
nurturing people along the path and so
it's getting more than just getting you
know measuring clicks it's it's
measuring actual hard dollars that were
generated based off specific channels or
specific pieces of content and then you
know it's developing an understanding of
sales goals what did the sales
department need information to an8 the
CRM so that they can nurture people
along in the path so it's more than just
marketing it's understanding that full
scope that a company has yeah that's an
excellent point and I think another
thing to keep in mind too is is use
actual conversations with your
salespeople
as a one of if anything it's something
that that marketing and sales often are
their own little silos and I think one
of the best things a marketer can do is
just go and talk to your best sales
people and ask them what why are people
buying us what are the what are they
what are the questions they are asking
you to answer I think that can be a
because those questions since they're
legitimately people that are that are
engaging with your sales people and
making purchases I think those are the
most valuable questions you can answer
in your copy oh absolutely I mean short
of talking to a customer talking to your
sales department is the best way to get
information on it now my before I got
into SEO I was in sales
I took sales training and and in you
know dealt directly with people so it
kind of I had that uh you know that view
of things but I I'm amazed at how much
people don't interact with their sales
department in order to learn uh you know
what do people need how do we answer
their questions what you know what do
they respond to but then also your sales
people are that first in line entering
information into the CRM and when the
leads are created through your marketing
efforts it'd be good to ask them what
additional information do you need that
would make a better lead you know there
and there are many times where we have
changed the site on the recommendation
of the sales team and you know we we may
not have it we didn't improve
conversions but we what we improved were
the the scenario through which the sales
call then came after the conversion and
increase the close rate just based on
changing the landing page or the Thank
You page after the registration right
and it's a good conversation to start
having with your sales fields who said
that they know what kind of questions to
listen to because a lot of times they're
just not paying attention you ask sales
for help they made the sale because I
was a great sales guy but the more you
the more you work with them as a team
and say that hey you know to get them
thinking about a little actually
listening what the customers are asking
for and pass it down on to you you know
that of course will help lead
attribution and and all the things you
said so yeah definitely
don't forget the human element in SEM
well and this gets to you know this
really gets to it
if the trend now is moving more towards
you know someone who can manage a full
stack it's also moving towards people
who understand how to align sales and
marketing goals and beyond that it's not
just you know like the example I gave
before it's not just okay we increase
the conversion rate of our registration
okay that's great
what how did that contribute to revenue
but now it's understanding that there
are things that we can do to increase a
closed rate that don't always take place
on the website but it's a process and so
now we're analyzing processes that can
be done electronically and then how do
we create a better revenue stream that
way how do we make a better nurture
process now we're getting into the
effectiveness of content in producing a
result rather than just you know a
conversion a sale or a lead now we're
looking at how do we make more money
based out of this and that's really it's
that big picture of understanding that
you know our job is not just to get
leads it's to create better
profitability which rewards everybody
it's understanding those touch points
from content you know so as content is
being pushed out does it answer the
question does it lead people to the next
stage how quickly does it lead them
there can you measure influence from
your content and you know through depth
of visitor to the depth of the page that
they got to and then again it's the
experience based on motivations can you
understand that can you tie together
what a customer was feeling at a
specific point through their nurture
stream or through this process as I said
if it's getting away from more just
stuff that happens on the site its
communications throughout the entire
process the entire lifecycle of a
customer that's all coming under the the
management really of the marketing team
right now is that entire customer
lifecycle I'm gonna Cajun management and
finally this is something a trend that
I've been seeing as well in terms of
jobs and hiring and also business
function o MCP did a survey at the
beginning of the year asking people
where they spent the most amount of
their time and specifically an SEO and
SEO managers and anyone who dealt with
SEO nearly 40 percent of their time was
spent uh presenting their research
presenting strategy as well as uh as
well as explaining their the reasoning
for that strategy and so SEO s you need
to become a lot more comfortable in
front of people presenting your findings
making recommendations presenting
opportunities trends and presenting it
in a persuasive format that shows not a
bunch of data charts but shows how smart
you are in creating new revenue
opportunities for the company that is
really where we see a lot of things
going are the presentation skills are
becoming part of the demand for
companies when they're dealing with tech
Oh fantastic it's a good some of that we
have an active question and answer
session happening here one is what do
you think of using a MP with react for
mobile optimized pages uh who is taking
it accelerated mobile pages beyond the
top stories aspect and it's really
making it the main it's actually taking
it not just in mobile but also make it
the main organic search results - yeah
how important is amp and I've seen other
things about amp with react specifically
related to - Clinton SEO that sometimes
amp may slow it down with what's the
real word of the street about amp I am
so torn on this amp is great for the
user if it loads fast
however it's at the expense of the
publisher um when amp first came out
publishers weren't getting the direct
visit um the the the visitor was not
technically theirs because they went to
a page that was a Google URL so in a way
you if you programmed it if you had your
analytics it honestly it was like a
hundred pages of terrible instructions
to get your coat on there so you could
get the page view but the problem was
they were on a Google URL it took that
Google well over a year and a half maybe
almost two years to give publishers
their own amp URL and and publishers
begin to develop and and do some
monetization on their amp pages the
problem is is that the system really
favors the larger publishers who can
bear those added costs for programming
to make it happen
and that's what's going on now with the
amp and the react programming is it's
you know the larger publishers they had
any publisher they've got to now react
to what Google has decided to do across
the board uh and so
they're gonna have to pay someone who
can figure this out who knows what to do
it's forcing publishers to accommodate
what Google's doing um honestly then
it's to me it's an exhibit another
example of Google co-opting other
people's work publishing it on their
site and keeping the visitor on their
platform and publishers that I know are
very very hesitant to speak out publicly
against it ah be for fear of Google
right so it's one of those things that
in some ways it can help some of your
bigger publishers are they're monetizing
well but again Google is setting the
tone for if you're going to play on our
playground here's the rules and so yeah
I think it's a great it's a great idea
but the execution of it is it's forcing
so much added expense for people to
figure out how to work with it
yeah and the documentation is lacking
yeah and there are a lot of companies
specifically out there they'll charge a
lot of money to do it for you right and
then you got to ask yourself well if I
pay to do this what's the return yeah um
yeah you know and I don't think the
return is there right now - you know for
a smaller publisher I'll take my chances
oh yeah and there do seem to be some I
have read some things out there about
how many it does negatively affect
content related for SEO so just had like
it's great for retail it's great for
e-commerce that sort of thing but yeah
your your mileage may vary but I'm not
especially if you're publishing
multimedia oh yeah it just doesn't work
well yeah so if you're a Moz follower
does it really matter to concern
yourself with unconfirmed Google
algorithms changes I mean how much of
the needle do you need to chase all
right I'm gonna let you in on a secret
here anyone who's on I don't know how
many people are listening here I have
been doing SEO now for over well yeah 25
years
I have no idea there's an algorithm
change I have no idea whatsoever
um it's much like the stock market if
you put money in and you watch the stock
market every day and you react to what
happens every day you're going to lose
money if you put your money in and you
let it sit and you just ignore
everything and you ignore the experts
and you ignore the pundits in 20 years
later you'll probably do really well um
Moe's has a great and loyal following
and they have built the if they have
branded themselves very well and they
built a great audience um but the more
you understand search the more you
understand you know Google tweaks their
algorithm literally I you know dozens of
times a day
uh so I'm I'm always wary of people that
overanalyze everything that recommend
something that you know because of this
the latest - you know honestly I think
it's overreacting but sensational
headlines get clicks so I to me the
worst thing you can do is react to
everything uh or you know and just the
vast you know I talked about what the
vast majority of SEO is giving people
what they want great content that
answers questions yeah I think even most
said that Google has said numerous times
that you you can't do anything specific
to fix your rankings
no fix for pages that perform less over
time just it just made your content will
rise and fall based on yeah looking
forward the quality of it so I'm in the
if you've got the basics covered you
know you know your architecture your URL
structure you know your page speed you
know those are the things really focus
on those because those are known
quantifiable factors is your structure
your page speed you know from a
technical standpoint the other side of
it is you know D answer people's
questions do they like you do they
search for you those are the types of
things you know it's really very simple
and I think sometimes people complicate
it a little too much you can't fool the
machines what does a what does Google
consider a good bad dwell time this
person's company has a one minute video
of pre-roll and realities that a low
dwell time specifically in the video
pages could those ad free rolls damage
our rankings I don't think so because
you have to look at the average dwell
time which is actually very low um you
know that might be something that you
would want to work on I don't think it's
going to damage your organic rankings on
google.com it may damage you know if
you're using YouTube on those areas of
where people are not watching the full
video that that's where I would see it
more affecting things but if you're
seeing that you know 90% of people are
only getting into 20% of your video you
may want to take another look at the
content or the structure or the
presentation and look at how you're
presenting that yeah definitely get what
you need to say in the first 20 seconds
then yeah before people can click that
five well commercials that I see even in
YouTube where you can skip after five
seconds and you haven't gotten past the
beauty shot yet Oh interesting people
will stay and watch if it's interesting
if it's something compelling they'll
stay and watch but the vast majority of
time they just want to get to their
video it seems like you're really
pushing the future of SEO as that of
learning other areas and becoming just
as adept and pay-per-click social
content marketing is that the cases it's
sort of a I know you mentioned earlier
that it's kind of a it's not a
specialist game anymore yeah I don't see
that happening and you know especially
with machine learning coming in um it's
going to take care a lot of those you
know technical functions it's going to
take care you know I think some of your
bidding
you know right now the Google bidding is
you know I I can't argue against it I
don't like I don't like Google writing
my content or my ad but the bidding side
is getting better um but yeah I think
the with machine learning AI over the
next ten years you're going to see a lot
of these individual specialties really
blur and you're going to have to
understand the full stack in order to
get promoted in order to get more
management opportunities well great well
let's just wrap this up with one
observation about how it seemed like
you're finishing this by stressing the
ability to present data persuasively how
important is this this is you know just
as much as understanding the full stack
when it comes to promotions when it
comes to management when it comes to
getting noticed the ability to present
data in a very persuasive and concise
manner is going to do a lot for your
career and so no more working in a dark
room and producing a report and sending
it along the pathway it's almost going
to I I think the demands are going to
increase on what you're doing and how it
contributes to the bottom line of the
company and those that do it well as
well as find new revenue opportunities
and present them those will be the one
that will be in a departments hmm great
well that's definitely good good career
advice and whether you're already
entrenched or looking for something new
so I just want to say thanks again to
Matt Bailey for joining us today
visit simply learn comm slash digital
marketing for info on how to learn more
best practices and getting certified and
if you have any further questions I
didn't get addressed during today's
presentation please go ahead and tweet
us at simply learn and of course Matt
what's your favorite social handle
people can reach you through on LinkedIn
Matt Bailey LinkedIn on LinkedIn quite
well thank you very much again Matt for
joining us now thank you
and we'll see you see you next time
thanks everyone
you